[MUSIC PLAYING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: It seems
machine learning is everywhere
nowadays.
And with so many offerings
for you as a mobile developer,
it can get really confusing
as to where you should start.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya, an
engineer on the Firebase team,
and I'm here today to introduce
you to the options that
are available to you.
If we could carry data
centers in our pocket
with unlimited battery,
it will be much easier.
But using ML for
mobile apps means
thinking about the processing
power, battery consumption,
and connectivity of our device.
There are a number
of factors that
will dictate the ML strategy
and tools you'll want to use,
like whether you want
to keep the data local,
if you require low latency,
or if you need access
to the processing
power of the cloud.
Luckily, Google offers
a number of ML options
for mobile developers
that can help
you develop and deploy ML
models for the environment that
fits your use case.
To help you pick which ML
deployment option fits best,
I'll walk you through a
few key decision points.
The first question you
should ask yourself
is where you want to
perform ML inferences--
in the cloud or on the device?
You would use a cloud if you are
already using an existing cloud
service for model inferences.
Or you run inferences
infrequently
and want to minimize impact
on the device battery life.
Or need to support older,
less performant devices.
Or if you need high-accuracy
models that require
the compute power of the cloud.
On the other hand,
there are cases
in which it might
be useful to do ML
inference on the mobile device.
For example, if you want to
keep data local to the device.
You need low latency, such as
RAM processing multiple frames
in quick succession.
You want inferences to work
even when the device is offline.
Or your users may be
in an area of the world
where high-speed
wireless connectivity
is non-existent or unreliable.
So now that you understand
all the considerations,
let me present the
options available to you.
First is to run
inference in the cloud.
And there's a wealth of
tools and APIs you can use.
These include Cloud Vision
for image recognition
and classification,
Cloud Natural Language
API for text parsing
and analysis,
AutoML, that allows
you to customize models
that are served from the cloud.
All are available via REST APIs.
I won't go into them all
here, but you can learn more
at cloud.google.com
/products/ai/building-blocks.
Next is to run
inference on the device.
And you have two main options.
You can either use
TF Lite directly
or you can use ML
Kit for Firebase.
ML Kit is a mobile SDK that
brings Google's machine
learning experience
to Android and iOS
apps in a powerful yet
easy to use package.
It comes with a set
of ready to use APIs,
both for on device and
cloud-based inference.
They support common
mobile use cases,
like image labeling, face
detection, text recognition,
and barcode scanning,
to name a few.
You simply pass in the
data to the ML Kit library
and it will give you the
information you need.
Whether you are new to or
experienced with machine
learning, you can implement
the functionality you need, all
in a few lines of code.
And it includes both
Android and iOS libraries.
[? While the ?] on device
APIs process data quickly
and will work even when
there's no network connection.
The cloud-based APIs
leverage the power
of Google Cloud
platform's machine
learning technology to give
a higher level of accuracy.
If you have a use case that's
different than offered models,
ML Kit also offers the ability
to deploy and experiment
with your own custom
TensorFlow Lite models
to run on device inference.
It works like this.
After converting your model
to the TF Lite format,
you can host and serve
it to your users.
ML Kit for Firebase can
then be used to host
and dynamically serve TF
Lite models to your users.
And it provides
convenient APIs that
help you use your custom TF
Lite models in your mobile apps.
With ML Kit for
Firebase, you can
reduce the initial install
size of your mobile app
and only download the
model when needed.
Dynamically swap
models on the fly
without having to republish
you app to the app store.
Target different user
segments with models
tailored specifically for them.
Run A/B experiments
with multiple models
to find the best-performing one.
If you'd like, you can
also use your TF Lite
model on mobile directly
with TF Lite APIs.
These offer blazingly
fast inference times,
particularly on Android devices
that support the neural network
APIs and the variety of ways
to host and deploy your model.
For mobile developers looking
to implement machine learning
into their apps, there
are several directions
to choose depending on how
much flexibility you want
or how specific
your use case is.
We covered some key factors
that help you decide,
like whether you do your
inference on the device
or in the cloud,
and whether you want
to use the pre-trained
models Google provides.
Or train and bring
your custom model.
Check out our full session
at Next for a deep dive
analysis, live experiments,
and the latest ML offerings
from Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]